this is a production of Cornell
University
so I want to talk about organic matter
in general but compost specifically and
how we're using some of those things and
I'm going to go through it with in a
different manner I'm going to go through
it by feedstocks by different things
that were using to compost because all
different composts and all different raw
materials have different challenges
associated with them so I want to I want
to look at it from that perspective can
we tell if that's a good compost right
there either color texture odor they're
good indicators good indicators but in
fact it's pretty hard to do without
testing and we know that that's an
expensive thing so what we've done is as
the waste management is to you we work
with all different feedstocks all
different materials and we do a lot of
testing our doing New York State Dec
allows us to pull samples from different
facilities and we get those tested in
depth so we have a large database of New
York State compost but we also have a
much larger one that we work with
nationally because we're working with
many other states and many other people
nationally and internationally we need
to know what our soils need so test
soils find out what nutrients are needed
see if a compost or an organic amendment
can even do that for ramen or can it
give us what we need for that do we
compost
do we digest so we have 2223 anaerobic
digesters for dairy manure in New York
State we have a whole lot for human
manure also in New York State and across
the states and I don't think we have I
don't know about in the South weather we
have a lot of digesters down in the
southern areas or not but we have a few
digesters here do we wanna put a
digestate on the fields it's a question
we're gonna go through a lot of it raw
manure do we want to put raw manures or
raw product it could be Apple pressings
great pressings hummuses all kinds of
things like that that we may be putting
on the soil as amendments and we have to
think about what form we're putting
those in can we have too much organic
matter Harold was just saying yeah we
can have too much organic matter in
certain soils and we have seen that in
some on some occasions I see the
opposite much more often than than than
that I see that we desperately need the
organic matter we need to be building
some of these soils for a lot of reasons
pH know your crop requirements so so why
compost there's a lot of organic
material out there we estimate that 60%
of the of the waste stream is organic
but guess what that doesn't include
human manure and it doesn't include
livestock manure when they're talking
about that being organic there's a lot
humans are major k foes we have you know
every city is major CAFO and we have a
lot of livestock K those people know
what K foes are yes
bye-bye composting we can reduce most of
those feedstocks by about 50% so we give
it in a more manageable form we don't
have to call it this far it reduces the
yuck factor doesn't burn well fills up
landfills converts organics to old soil
like product not a soil it's a soil
amendment still it's not a fertilizer
but it has nutrients depending on what
for our food stocks are what did I think
one of the most important things to look
at is is this one soil moisture soil
moisture we're seeing a lot of drowning
we're seeing a lot of temperature
increases we're seeing a lot of really
really dry soils at the wrong times if
we can get more organic material into
these into these soils it will help hold
some of them some of the some of the
water moisture in the soils it helps
suppress plant diseases we don't know
all the answers to that not even going
to guess sometimes we've looked at very
young compost medium composts only only
dairy compost you know we've we've got
all over the place with looking at those
and there's been a lot of good research
but we know that we when we create a
whole system when we have a good organic
we have a good soil good aggregate
stability that we have better disease
protection there's more things to fight
for more organisms to fight the other
disease organisms improve soil quality
clean compost and I'm a big one on
talking about clean compost and that's
why we're going to go through some of
these feedstocks is we want to have good
clean compost and that is without a lot
of heavy metals pathogens or a different
thing we'll talk about that as we come
to this
actually does this compost
oh yes the composting process does right
it does very effectively and and yes no
no I'm not not alluding to the fact that
we're not it's not wiping out pathogens
we've done a lot of research some of the
work that I do that that we do is
composting deadstock so i compost lots
of dead animals I'll talk a little bit
as we get to some of those slides and we
certainly have pathogens and those need
to be aware of the pathogens that we
might be just having soils have your
compost tested and there are different
labs there this is one from from the our
see now this is another one out west it
just know what you know what your
compost looks like I know what that
class of compost then if you think you
have a problem then definitely test I
think I'm going to skip these right now
but one of the things I made a list of
questions up because people are like
well with what should I be using and
some of it is what's what are the
feedstocks we need to know those what
are the carbon sources is it generated
off farm if yes which pipe feedstocks
are all farm we need to know about all
of those things to be able to make a
good good choice on what compost you're
using R is the farm using copper sulfate
or formaldehyde copper sulfate is going
to concentrate in the manure and we've
seen the copper in the soils going up
around the dairies where we where we're
using copper sulfate and we worked with
about 25 darienne's to look at their
compost what they had as finished
compost
all the law almost all the large dairies
use copper sulfate or zinc sulfate
Australia has a problem with zinc
sulfate because they use with zinc assay
you think sulfate we have more of a
problem with copper sulfate formaldehyde
breaks down pretty cleanly but it's a
worker health problem so just need to
know are there pesticides and herbicides
used on the crops that were composting
pesticides and herbicides you know what
are you what are used and one of the
problems one of the reasons we ask that
question is because we have some very
potent herbicides out there that are not
breaking down well
chloral live and amino gorillas and a
lot of states are having problems with
that pretty much in the Northeast we've
banned the use of the Caparo lid that
compound that active ingredient because
one of the things that can happen with
with that compound is it can go through
it can be it can be sprayed on the crop
you can go through the animal's body you
can go into a
pooped-out go into a compost pile and
still kill broadleaf plants a year later
so if you're gonna use it back on a
grass crop it's okay but if you're going
to use it on it's okay we think I mean
I'm going to say it's okay not to kill
the kill the broadleaf plants but we
have to think about that I was teaching
in Idaho I teach in a lot of different
states I don't teach as much hike
Cornell but I teach all over to Train
regulators and stuff like that and in
Idaho they were having a heck of a
problem with the floral we had the
problems in Vermont with amino curly
because one of the problems with with it
is even though we've banded in the
Northeast we import hay when we have a
bad hay year we
the import Jorge is goes all over the
world it goes in planes so Jorge is
amazing thing moves brand all over and
they do use amino para live on on horse
so that question how long is the
material being composted is it immature
and immature is it old old old is too
old I don't think that can really happen
but the hay or the bedding you know what
where is the hay from is it screened
some people want you know he said
something about particle size really
really fine we had a facility in Florida
at one point that took the whole wave
stream and and hounded the whole way of
stream to death so it looked like a soil
but it was in the soil it wasn't a
compost it was pulverized waste stream
and it when we looked at it chemically
and physically it looked like that so it
had the sneakers in it and it had the
glass it which that's actually a fine
thing to have but but some of the others
just aren't so we can't take a whole
waste stream and and compost it together
or pulverize it and think that that's
gonna happen so particle size is is a
good thing and we like neatness we might
like that small particle size but one of
the things we found out I have a slide
on it later a lot of things we found out
is that the compost that's not turned is
much better you know that's passively
aerated maybe turned once or twice is
much better compost as far as N and
organic matter to put into the ground
for that crop so it's one thing that you
know we looked at we looked at the farms
that we followed the practices the farms
were using and figured all that house
all kinds of feedstocks food waste and
these are color coded because people
don't get the idea between carbon and
nitrogen Browns and the Greens the wet
sand the dries so we color-coded them
because
okay maybe people will get that a little
bit better so and these are a little off
right now sorry the colors but food
waste is mostly a nitrogen source food
processing ways also manure both dairy
manure both poultry manure or not so
much sometimes it is sometimes it's not
but we garden residual leaves yard waste
pond weeds fish and meat bio solids bio
solids are human manure so when I'm
talking about bio solids we'll just go
through that way and dairy waste dairy
waste can be liquid waste acid way
things like that that were you there
they're actually food processing bases
heavily and dairy leaf and yard
residuals so what's the what are the
problems with leaf in yard waste it's a
good thing and EPA got the idea a couple
of years back five six seven years back
thinking oh we can incorporate leaves
into the farm field in New Jersey we did
that the farmers had done that for years
and years and years before that because
in the East we have a lot of trees we
have a lot of leaves and we can use that
organic matter for long term organic
matter and so farmers would apply the
leaves in the fall and then you know
they would be tilling them in and then
they would would get benefit from those
and the EPA study said yeah yeah we're
getting benefit from himself it ratified
that so what the farmers have been doing
for a long time was filled with some of
the problems with leaves is how they are
collected and how they're managed and
inerts so garbage in them sometimes you
know hubcaps for our sewer covers or
maybe a skunk or a dead cat or you know
there's all kinds of things that are
thrown in and picked up with the leaves
we collect us as municipalities we
collect
leaves in different ways sometimes we
suck them up with a vacuum truck
sometimes we scoop them up with a loader
okay so when we suck them up we're
taking all that little particulate
matter that's on the ground also so it's
the lead from the blood paint on the
roads and the residual edge from
gasoline so there's definitely lead in
and they expect that they'll be led in
our leaves for for a while for you know
they think probably a hundred years
it'll be around because the lead paint
on the roads the striping and stuff like
that they didn't stop that as fast
the gasoline they stopped but we're
still seeing a lot of that that LED
residual there it's not enough not to
use it it's still low levels but we're
seeing so if we're seeing it we should
think about it
so lettuce is one of those things in New
York City they're actually looking
they're trying to reduce the lead there
500 gardens 500 you know guard gardening
green thumb type Gardens in New York
City there's a four acre farm there's a
couple of four acre farms in there right
in New York City we're looking at the
lead levels in those places and saying
okay how can we get cleaner soil into
New York City New York City's a rock
great so what they're doing is they're
taking the subsoil when they're digging
for buildings and lots and stuff like
that so they're taking the subsoil and
putting that someplace so they can
stockpile that and then bringing organic
matter in we make a lot of a lot of
compost in New York City and around New
York City
but the stuff that's made in New York
City still has that residual lead levels
with residual is levels that we don't
want so they're bringing more compost in
to the city into New York City so that
they can ameliorate that problem and try
to I don't believe in dilution is the
solution to pollution but we have to
dilute those soils with something else
so that it
less available and we can tie up some of
those materials salt levels we use road
salts
so with road salts we have high salt in
our leaves as well again a lot of it is
is composted outdoors and under the sky
so a lot of it leeches that a lot of
those salts leach right to the ground
and we don't have to worry about that
some food scraps that looks like pretty
good food it's I think some Google
actually in New York City and it's the
composter there but it looks like pretty
edible setup
unfortunately food high in salt so any
of the food waste is high in salt
physical contaminant so physical
contaminants gloves ketchup packages
little cups from man mayonnaise you know
all that kind of stuff potentially is in
there the other one is that big one the
big one that we deal with rusty the
stupid labels from the apples oranges
know this stuff I mean they become
crumbs when they get composted but it's
still a contaminant you know it's still
a little bit a little bit more plastic
that's going into the environment and we
keep doing that keep putting that in
so if it'll clean diamonds and it varies
with feedstocks or you have very very
little seed stock we can even see it
seasonally and holiday wise you know the
differences in in food scraps doesn't
mean we shouldn't do it and are we gonna
compost food scraps alone no we have to
have a carbon source to go along with
that food scrap and one of my points to
anybody who makes compost is use as many
different seafoods
feedstocks as possible to get a good
balanced compost because you'll have a
better compost that way unless you
really need a very specific thing you'll
have a more diverse compost with a more
diverse suite of microorganisms
so mixing stuff up so a lot of
communities are going to food waste
composting and they're mixing it in with
their leaves or with woodchips or with
other things and that really is a great
marriage because leaves have just too
much carbon to really break down as well
as they should when we marry them with
with compote with with foods food waste
we have a much better product if people
have questions feel free manure high in
organic matter yes no Harold indicated
that it was we worked on some stuff we
would worked on a study where we had 25
farms that we were working with and we
were amazed at how it fluctuated and
I'll show you a slide on why that was
but low in contaminants it's pretty low
in contaminants
generally speaking we got all the sharps
out so we used to you know we used to
give the pig or the the cow shot and and
drop the needle that was common practice
that doesn't happen anymore all sharps
all needles are put someplace else so we
rarely see them I mean 10 years ago we
could go out to even Cornell compost and
where we have four acres of company and
we could see needles regularly now we
just see silverware so the silver plates
occasionally I get I have I have whole
bunches of silverware from all these
colleges let's make quick because
students tend to just chuck it out with
it and it's it's stainless steel
sometimes really nice stuff blowing
contaminants we don't have to worry
about that much except for the one thing
that I had said earlier and that was the
copper so if we're using copper sulfate
we have to watch out for the copper in
those it's high in phosphorous those
polt poultry and and we have two very
large poultry operations in New York
State there are more than that but in
in the upper part of the New York State
and they grow a lot of our vegetables
most of their is they're owned by the
same company and their material goes out
and it goes out in different forms
sometimes it composted sometimes it's
it's a litter you know just basically
litter so that is composted in most of
our whole trees do compost because of
the odor issues and because of the
strength of that that's just really high
ammonia and nitrogen in in poultries
pharmaceuticals most of them break down
pretty well and I don't have any
examples of how they are not so we look
at those in bio solids and we can see
that in bio solids we have broken down a
human waste we have written down a lot
of those materials and some has been
done on on we've done a little bit on
NSAIDs in NSAIDs barbiturates an
thematics so we've done a little bit of
work on on those and we've had good
results with that been able to see those
breakdown well I have not done any work
with antibiotics I know that people
there are people that have and they seem
to break down most of them break down
pretty well we'll probably have that one
that doesn't as well and if we aren't
looking we're not going to find so it's
one of those things that we do have to
think about so manure compost this is
just a sampling of different operations
we don't use names for anybody but the
organic matter so these are all very and
look at the organic matter levels in
those okay yeah there's some decent ones
but there's you're like okay but isn't
it a little organic matter one of the
things that we found out was that when
farms are composting the farms that are
are handling their manure with equipment
Machinery and putting it on a cement pad
they have higher organic matter what's
happening is most people compost on soil
compacted soil or some kind of pad
sometimes cloth and gravel bed or
whatever and they're paying up soil so
they're in training soil when every time
they pick something up there getting
some soil so if it's a bar and that's
got a I'm just curious if somebody was
interested in putting in a large
composting facility what type of soil
would they be looking for if they could
have a choice house and you wouldn't
want to use a gravelly soil or last
tonight is good if I'm looking at a pad
I really like coffee shop because cloth
and gravel is I am biased Cornell uses
it I didn't put it in the farm services
put it in and you can run on that all
the time you have a foot of gravel you
have geotextile I'm sorry you have a
geotextile so what they've done is they
taking the soil off then they put that
textile down and then they put a foot 18
inches of gravel on top of that and then
they compact it and it's just a
beautiful surface to run on they don't
like cement
I don't like asphalt because it's a
permanent thing you have to use a
jackhammer but take it away soils when
we're composting on farms so most soils
are where clay soils are hard to get on
and off in the winter or when it's wet
and rainy so those can be problematic
but but you can compost you know on soil
and what I encourage farms to do is to
put it put the compost where they're
going to be applying it in the field so
if they want to stack Windrose if they
want to build a windrow then build that
windrow out on the edge of the field and
then you don't have to move it so many
times and what you really want to do is
you want to create that wind row
right on the edge of the field and then
it will work by itself if it can be
stacked if you can stack it up it'll
generally work sometimes it's slower
than others because you might have some
bedding in there you might have no
bedding in there you might have sand in
there so all of those things are going
to act a little bit differently but if
you can get it out there and just get it
in a windrow that shape of the windrow
helps facilitate the process it allows
the air to go around that and facilitate
the process
fecal coliform you know some of these
were not finished compost and another
one is that would like a look at is this
weed seeds weed seeds per liter
there weren't Leeds weed seeds in it
because it was manure that was a
situation where I had to pull weeds that
are taller than I am to to get down to
the compost so the wheat the seed bank
was already there if once once you know
plants go to seed they're gonna get
right into that compost and say hey we
got a really good medium to grow it and
and you're gonna see heats all over the
place because mixing it in with soil yes
you're actually mixing it in with the
soil even if the operator the loader
operator is very good at this we're
seeing it again and again and we could
show it the differences because we have
farms that have digesters and everything
is it goes it's moved conveyed to a
lagoon and then it's separated then it
goes never touches the ground so we were
able to say okay that's maybe why and
that's how we could explain some of it
mental results just to show you what the
Middle's look like we've got copper and
a copper line here okay so under the New
York state levels
way above New York State soil levels you
know what our typical unamended soil
would be would be the 20 but you can see
anybody who is using it and metals
accumulate in soil so if you're applying
two years in a row three years in a row
you're going to have too much copper
there fats oils and greases another
problematic material that we deal with I
do as I said before I do a lot of
mortality composting and teach people to
do a lot of mortality composting pie and
nutrient we're seeing an NPK of two to
two in those and one thing that I didn't
do the research on this but somebody in
Guelph found out by accident is that
some of the fats
hold some of that hold the M in the
product so I don't know how accurate
that is but the the meat waste is
definitely higher in nutrients as a
finished product physical contaminants
pretty low we don't have a lot of those
and use limitations we do encourage
people not to use it on food crops you
know food food crops it can be used on
some feed crops and when we're doing
like mortality know when we're doing
mortality composting and I have a couple
slides afterwards if we have time to get
there
we do use a lot of food we have used if
we we had a disease outbreak of high
path avian influenza west of the
Mississippi in 2015 okay we lost fifty
million turkeys and chickens how many
people know that probably most right I'm
hoping people yeah so we went out and we
composted all that so there are 10 12 of
us that just went out and directed
operations on what to do
we had miles and mile
piles all of that material in in three
three months went back onto the field we
killed the HPAI the high path avian
influenza in probably 30 minutes of it
reaching temperature what vegans eat
I've had that question from her mom
before you know and that's when I can't
answer that question don't see you don't
see what it's not an issue so we do have
berries that have our dairies are out
there they have mortality they compost
their mortality if they have a thousand
cows they have 40 dead cows to deal with
right now okay each year they'll have
about 40 dead cows that they've got to
do something with so we do teach them to
compost is it really true that you know
at one time when we had this mad cow
disease a lot of people suspected that
it could be stat woman virus being
spread Mac Apple made from those cows
right we do not claim to that's the one
thing so pathogens we can deal with all
the pathogenic organisms in the
composting process because we're cooking
it at temperature 130 to 160 degrees
okay so we have that thermophilic
compost BSE any prion diseases are not
killed there they're generally killed at
1500 1700 degrees Fahrenheit so they're
really a high temperature kill or
disabling
so we're not claiming to do that in the
u.s. we don't tend to have we were
monitoring our populations and we don't
have mad cow we do have chronic wasting
disease in the United States and we do
have scrapy
the United States and we had nice prions
now we have a lot of other things I
would all be pretty sick if if we if
something in the environment wasn't
taking care of these crayons so no I
don't think you should be eating we were
feeding cows to cows so we're feeding
cow protein to cows that was a problem
that can definitely transfer disease if
there's disease there to transfer and
cows really aren't meat eaters their
stomach is not really meant to do that
but it wasn't it wasn't a dad try but it
just was causing problems so it is not
allowed to happen in the u.s. they do we
have specified risk materials which are
the brain the lymph nodes the tongue
spinal cord those are all the materials
that need to come out of the animal and
and camp almost anymore and that's
that's the preventive for us for us
getting into that so even the specified
best materials in US and Canada would
end up going to a landfill biosolids
it's very available very available
inerts yep it's got all kinds of stuff
we can tell our manure from cow manure
why we wear PLAs I'm not wearing plastic
was anybody wearing something plastic
well you got to wear a lot of glass and
clothes when we watch them all that goes
in microbeads all that stuff goes in
from cleansers which we've stopped using
now but we have so many micro plastics
around and associated with humans that
we can tell our manure from there when
it's when it when we shouldn't be you
know when it's when it's all said and
done you just always tell the difference
so definitely inerts might not be able
to see them but
they're their chemical contaminants
everything we had a situation in there's
a product called Minh milorganite that
comes out of Milwaukee their ships
better than Irish so we import it to New
York and to a lot of other places they
had somebody obviously there's no other
way it could happen dumped mercury down
the drain and it ended up in the sewage
sludge so they had to recall that
probably six seven years ago but they
had to recall all this milorganite
because it was effective it was high in
mercury at that point so we can't tell
and if we don't look we're not going to
know bacteria we can we can wipe out all
the bacteria there
we do have regrowth problems because we
are such a large CAFO as humans that
they process it try to process it faster
so they have regrowth issues with
pathogens how the genes get turned back
in and then they go and they say oh
there's more food here I can keep going
and that happens viruses we can take
care of most viruses drugs break down
pretty well you're talking about change
and feedstock use limitations we have
federal and state laws on how we can use
bio solids whether it's Class A Class B
it is regulated but I know a lot of the
facilities and they'll test and test and
test until they get the rate results so
it's a it's unfortunate you know they're
they they have to process it further but
they they will go till they get the
right result so just I'm just going to
show you a couple of quick different
this is a right here on route 81 right
here in New York State they compost
organic dairy manure and lake weeds food
scrap some food scraps with food
processing this is one of those Windrose
from 15 million turkeys and chickens and
they went for miles
and these are we had to do them in barns
because it was a disease outbreak but
all of that material is good it's all
fertilizing the fields west of the
Mississippi right now so there were a
lot of it and and everybody's put it out
and they're growing good crops with it
at this point and that's that's the best
disposal method another just another
shot Multi bin system anybody here from
North Carolina also know we composted
all of the turkeys are all the chickens
and a few turkeys after the Florence
floods last year so we went into the
barn sucked out the it was liquid birds
and suck the stuff out newer bedding
birds and got that into compost piles
multi bin systems just another way this
is an agitated bass system the auger
just slowly goes up and down those and
narrates these this is a large dairy
farm that digests and then they separate
and put it into the into those long bins
and at one point they had a lot of PVC
perforated PVC pipe under it they had
fans attached to it well at that point
they didn't need to do either so they
get they sold their fans and they
eventually stopped putting the PVC under
it they were able to naturally aerate
naturally contact with that even with
the jersey barriers there that cement
barriers forced air systems we use some
of them mostly we use them for bio
solids but we do use some for other
things for food waste and other things
in New York State and others under
states rotating our rotating drums in
New York the only thing we're using I
think I don't even know if we have a
farm left that's using them for bedding
they're using their dairy manure solids
and processing them in the drum to put
back underneath the cows so
vermicompost we have Crowley to
vermicompost facilities this one's a
very large Verma Cyberman composting
facility compost the manure or processes
the manure from two thousand cows this
one goes through at thermophilic phase
and then it's fed to the worms after we
run up through the thermophilic phase
just a two-week thermophilic and then
and that's how it's done in the other in
in all of our new york vermicompost we
only have to use a special yeah so it's
it's a yeah they had to grow up enough
to be able to run that facility because
it's not easy to get to get those those
mom ones no red wigglers are a very
short i don't think i have a picture
yeah yes about this big very thin
process they can eat about three times
there await their Epogen so they are
they're surface feeders they can eat
about three times their weight per day
what's that yes yes you can you need as
much as they needed yeah you have to
grow them up so they have populate their
beds as they went but they they do
reproduce well especially if they're
under those perfect conditions but but
it does work and that's worth about that
yard of compost is worth about three to
five hundred dollars it goes to high end
greenhouse operations so composting
liquids we do a lot of that to as I said
with the poultry and stuff this is
fifteen thousand gallons of Ben and
Jerry's weeks so that's something that
was composted they make a trough in the
middle and then
instead of turning it you just cover it
so and then when it's also when it also
clean and starts processing then you can
start turning it but they can put
fifteen thousand gallons in a 100 foot
window a hundred yard window for you
know three to four weeks so and I will
end there this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu